three days after leaving russia alexei
navalny
is still in an artificial coma but his
life
is no longer in immediate danger
according to the doctors treating him
since arriving in berlin he's undergone
intensive tests
and they indicate he was poisoned
in a detailed statement the hospital
said that the clinical findings
indicate intoxication by a substance
from the colinar teres inhibitor group
the specific substance
has not been identified so far and a
further wide-ranging analysis
has been initiated it stops the
breakdown
of a neurotransmitter in your body
that helps with movement and messages
being sent across
on nerve cells this neurotransmitter
acetylcholine
um needs to be broken down and what this
drug does
is it stops that breaking down of this
drug
so the effect that the neurotransmitter
has
keeps going which means you can develop
severe twitching
severe sweating breathing difficulties
seizures
and in a coma or die from it these
findings
completely contradict the russian
diagnosis doctors in siberia
had previously suggested that navalny
was suffering
from low blood sugar levels the hospital
was very careful to say
that the tests been run a number of
times and independently verified
because they want to establish their
credibility but also they'll be aware
that the findings will be controversial
certainly in moscow
and it could lead to a diplomatic
fallout the remains a sizeable police
presence
inside and outside the hospital where
alexei navaoni is being treated
the german government is taking no
chances
it was clear that protective measures
had to be taken after his arrival here
after all this is a patient on whom a
poisonous attack has been committed
with a certain probability angela merkel
has called for an immediate
and transparent investigation she is
satisfied
that navalny was poisoned and the
british government agrees
the kremlin is yet to respond alistar
bunco sky news
berlin